hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast leveraging recent
advances in milk in yeast cell sorting
automation platforms to reduce time to
data and primary cell based assays
presented by dr. Nick Trotter Mayo
Global key account manager Pharma Milton
G biotech on Julie simmer alpha lab
groups and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
an opportunity biotech for more
information about our sponsor visit
Milton EVO techcom before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click the green
Q&A button located in the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation for questions not
answer today we will follow up with
participants via email also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
icon located on the lower right of the
screen
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and does offer us free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now please
join me in welcoming dr. Trotter Mayo I
will now turn the presentation over to
him thanks Julie actually mentioned I'm
Nick Shar now I'm part of military
provocation team which finish being
networked with a bunch started by
pharmaceutical companies working on
different platforms and asset of the
research and I just want to play about a
couple of the things we did with
different groups and some new platforms
we developed that building enhance our
ability to automate cell sorting and
introduce some time that it takes to
generate data and garments of these
assets
so um just moving forward no penny is a
global leader in the life sciences and
cell therapy industry the company itself
is independently owned so it's privately
held we've been in business about 27
years we've grown to be about 1,800
employees with more than 400 people in
R&D and engineering and those corners
people are really the heart of the
company and enablement to be vertically
integrated for production of instruments
consumables and biological products
Nitori thing we'll talk about today not
any manufactures itself and because we
have a pretty big R&D group and
engineering group we have a real history
of advancing both basic and
translational research
everybody relational research is really
referring to our work in software
entry so we have global operations
across 25 countries and this is kind of
a global map from Oltenia where we are
racing these little purple triangles or
where we have actual instance locations
or subsidiaries in 25 different
countries
the company itself is German that's two
major sites in Germany the first Asian
virg.guad lock which is right outside
colonial headquarters for most of our
R&D is done and product production but
we also have a facility in Tetro
which manufactures GMP products which
are sort of our regulated products are
their views and in the u.s. we've seen a
pretty big expansion of our footprint
leave us with now advocate excite
including some R&D engineering going on
so
rotating is is really known for its
magnetic deep platforms and sorting
cells using magnetic beads and that's
certainly what we'll spend a lot of the
time today talking about but when I
think about our company what I think we
really developed in last 27 years is
really world-class expertise in cell
processing and really what we've been
advancing in the last five to ten years
it's increasingly generating these
integrated and automated workflows for
éxito cell processing so taking blood or
tissue from a patient or an animal model
and really putting it through an
optimized procedure so that we have the
best possible self product at the end of
that whatever
the downstream and quite a say those
different categories break down on a
couple of different lines so we have a
sample preparation which is our genomics
platforms which enables the ability to
generate a single cell suspension and
then there's no separation platforms
which are many platforms and again we'll
talk about that quite a bit today and
then in the cell culture space for
primary cell culture we have a bunch of
different technologies for activation
expansion transduction specifically as
other things in a lot of the culture so
and then finally fell analysis we'll
talk about a little bit at the end of my
talk which is our flow portfolios which
includes instrumentation and reagents
and also now first order data so that's
kind of a basic introduction to us as a
company for today and what I'd like to
achieve with this presentation is to
early a five section the first is just
to give you a basic introduction to the
magnetic lead technology or what we call
max technology and this is the
technology will use in the next couple
of sections we talk about specific news
contribution and technologies and hours
and leveraging them with customers and
then we'll kind of talk about two
central themes of what are some low key
challenges that we've been working with
customers on who are using primary cell
based assays and the problems they've
been having and how we've helped solve
them by working with them and so you can
kind of get follow with this two
challenges are based on these next
couple sections but really it's
discussing strategies for the effective
and really large cell numbers so having
a single product that has a lot of
elements with billions of cells or tens
of billions or so and this is this idea
of working that whole new compact scale
and certainly talk about that in more
detail and now if you understand what
that means and then give you some
specific examples as well cell types
we've used and then kind of switching
gears is really now talking about having
a single sample that's too large to be
processed but having too many samples to
effectively process in a given unit of
time so the idea of multiplexing cell
sorting and working in AI throughput
environment and this could certainly be
lots of patient samples like someone's
blood
are coming and they need to be processed
to purify cells for the example we'll
use is actually a mouth tumor model are
we looking at enriching the tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes before immunity
no pectin so we're kind of using that as
the case study and finally in just a few
slides we'll return to this idea of cell
analysis and extending the analysis of
those isolated primary cell populations
by using 384-well photometry wrote
atomic stream and this is an
introduction to a new instrumental
finish just released called the mexicoís
X which enables 384-well plate base flow
cytometry and then cut it in the final
slide just talk about how using
terminate will upload to make primary
cell particularly screening activities
more realistic because miniaturization
of the athlete rather then I'll take
some questions so just taking the first
point there the instructions of AX
technology which is the technology we
use on not only using a nano sized
magnetic bead so this was a 50 nanometer
particle it's composed of iron protein
and sugar so it's completely
biodegradable and it's really really
small and in addition for that you can
see that there's a see dat solder on the
upper right hand here that you can see
and basically they've labeled it here
with some micro beads and then guided by
scanning electron microscopy and you can
see really at the magnification with
cell we really can't see the beads
they're just too small to be seen and
then we use a column based system to
enrich so labeled with these magnetic
beads and a separator which is really
the magnet and we'll spend some time
talking more about the colony magnets
but the technology itself can be used
for positive isolation a specific
population expansion of unwanted cells
so just attending a single population or
untouched isolation which means to
fitting all the non-target code and
allowing then the target population
doesn't chase boat appears at all so
unlike some other commercial systems out
there max use column
and often it's not clear to our
customers and others why we use comes
and it really goes back to the side and
the magnetic particles so if you
remember we have this little 15 area
meter piece of iron that is coupled to
the monoclonal antibody and if you
calculate the force you need to catch
that little tiny particle it's really
big magnetic field and so to
successfully do this we use a column and
column has the steel bone matrix and the
civil matrix is bending the magnetic
field line around the steel balls and
amplifying the field and it's increasing
the density of those lines which is
shown here on drawings arrow and you can
see that there are increasing number of
magnetic field lines in there and where
that field is high it is where the cells
will actually arrest which are these
little purple cells that are inside this
right figure and so where the field is
weaker
we have washing non-target fills through
the column and so by using this column
it allows you to use a very small
particle and successfully for ourselves
so we do this by with minimal labeling
and then the comic self is coated with a
self friendly sort of hydrophilic
coating and so things can wash through
it and so we get attractive removable
debris and contaminants and so the
outcome of using columns and usually
small beads is that they enable
celebration including positive selection
with a really normal affect themselves
versus other sort of negative see
technology we actually look at just
doing a sort it's really straightforward
so we have a magnetic labeling step
which is just putting the D particle on
the target position and this left graph
over here I'm drawing arrow we're doing
bottoms of selection so and so we're
labeling either sell that we want to
sort and so the idea is this purple cell
where I drew the arrow has a
differentially expressed damage
including a cd4 on a t cell that we can
label with the feed particle and now
once we've labeled a population we put
the column in the magnetic field we get
this high gradient magnetic field
introduced without the single cell
dysfunction Freeza column again all this
non target cells
slowly through the column and into the
negative fraction which is tiara I'm
drawing this arrow now
and then finally remove the column for
magnetic field and Aleut and it gives us
either Pierce cell in a really graphic
fashion and this technology has been
widely used over the last 27 years some
thousands and thousands of publications
and really has acknowledged the vehicle
standard for both research and clinical
based cell sorting so that's kind of a
basic introduction to max technology and
really what we're going to talk about in
the next section is how to apply that
and there are a lot of different ways
that you can use the same technology and
interact with it so in those 27 years
made a bunch different hardware and so
this just gives you a basic break on
different types of hardware that you can
use to sort those so we have manual
Hardware which these are widely
available and kind of walk around your
laboratory where you do research or
publicity so we'll be playing it out and
these are just male based systems with
the columns indictments where you're
getting all the pipetting work yourself
through an automation it expanded the
male hardware in the last few years to
make it higher throughput and more
multiplex so that we can run up to 24
channels at a time with this instrument
and work in Excel 24 plus and then for
automated hardware options we have this
automatic row which has been our
standard offering for audited instrument
the other guys it's kind of a workhorse
system for us and it but it's only
around between one and six samples and
it's scale versus some newer platforms
is somewhat limited when we talk about
200 members so we've expanded our
capabilities and the automated space by
adding some tuning instruments one is
the multi necks which the instrument
will spend a fair bit of time talking
about which is the automated version of
the multi mexico 24 plus this really
operations speed versus the other
platforms like the atom X Pro to much
faster is now working multiplex format
and then the other instrument the clinic
strategy is really developed to do
clinical building and motor still
clinical swords for self therapy work
but it's been applied by our research
customers because it really offers an
expansion scale
so researchers can sort more so and it
giving me the time insert with larger
cell products because these two
platforms have really expanded our
ability in the automation space versus
what was previously capable with just
the autumn X Pro so kind of coming back
to the idea of what are the challenges
that only work with customers and
certain firearms okay it's what are they
really facing are they coming to this
you know it's making their work
difficult and when they start thinking
about doing primary cell based assays so
a lot of these drug screens and other
things used to be done more with tissue
culture cells and now they're
increasingly down primary cell models
and that creates some challenges so
they're really two challenges we'll talk
about today and how we address them with
to to the platform the first one of
those scale based challenge and this
really just means that performing the
assay or the screen that these
researchers need to do requires billions
of primary cells and because of the cell
number that they need is scaling really
difficult to achieve with current
platforms and we'll talk about this a
little bit more in detail then there are
three quick challenges where they're
essentially just too many samples to
prop grow using given resources or the
available time so that the throughput is
just not able to be achieved easily and
so we'll talk about each of these and a
couple degrees and how we solve these
with different platforms when we look at
the first challenge is comparison scale
between common story of Technology so
there are a certain sort of technology
that close the target area max continues
to open on time this is essentially just
a logarithmic graph he's a lot better at
graph paper where you can plot between
one hundred thousand cells and on your
feelings no card here so on the right
side and so you're still number is
increasing in millions as we go along
the x-axis here and if we just kind of
plot different technologies globally
sorting which probably is occurring that
varied elements per second or less you
can easily do sorts of up to 200 million
cells and a given unit of time you could
do more but now you're starting out of
one resource and sometimes the liability
can become major issues
and so really what we're we're focused
on is what's kind of easily to do here
max had a more expanded capacity for
self processing that's really going up
to a billion zones but once you got
north through a billion cells with
existing price points we really started
to struggle with the number of cells we
had and with some inspiring five days
where we need a billion purified cells
starting with a billion total source
really is enough proof enough scale so
that's really when many of our research
customers start looking for solutions
and make sorted upon with our help that
it's going to match publishing system
can really expand the scales that we can
do so the kind of X prodigy Kingdom the
process up to about sixty million cells
per run and the really key thing here is
that it exists in sort of the scale
where people who work with commercial
liquor acts work and we'll explain more
about what the loop effects are and the
scale of these things both essentially
it's around 10 billion cells with kind
of the key number that usually want to
be working out with a lot of these
large-scale primary cell assays because
that's the starting material is
available and to learn these other two
technology exploding your net
traditional max really are able to
extend out to that sort of scale that
desired scale it's really required to do
these sorts so the second challenge I'm
just kind of investigating a little
further is just looking at visually just
picking one of our platforms so the
audience is my little cartoon autumn X
Pro that we introduced to you earlier
which is I kind of standard on the it
cell sorter um many people have asked is
now where they're getting 20 30 40
samples at a time this could be clinical
samples they can be samples for bites
but later tumors this creates some
challenges but essentially we would set
up and running down the necks before run
to do 24 samples because we go in
programs dixit and six handfuls per run
and the other max works sequentially
through samples so it's only processing
one pinpoint time and so if it takes ten
minutes per sample which is a reasonable
time sorts to occur and you know 24
sample essentially that works out to
being four hours of short time if you
prep steps before these four hours to
start maybe an hour to prep work tissues
my extra other things in the running or
you're very late in your working day
before you're actually setting up your
final ad days or other things so many
customers we've worked with have seen
that the automatic systems to start fast
enough and the autumn X's are generally
faster clothes sorting clothes not
really an option in there so there was a
real gap and the needs of sort of the
market space for for hire different cell
sorting acknowledging okay so that's
kind of the two key problems that are
facing the field and then we'll really
talk about each of those problems and
how we dress them and so in this next
section we're going to kind of revisit
that first problem the scale based from
and really talking about strategies for
effective handling of large cell numbers
or large starting numbers of cells
before we do cell sorting and we'll
introduce the idea of what is we provide
scale sorting and we will give you an
introduction to the contacts prodigy
system what is it how does it work
and then we'll take kind of two case
studies where we look at the isolation
if you negatory T cells which is a rare
so example and there's an automated
generation of modified on site for us to
critic cells show you the full cake
protocol system so when people are
wanting to scale at work with primaries
immune immune cells a natural place to
go is to the caprices product so we're
capricious products are essentially the
donor is connected to an instrument that
removes preferentially certain white
cell populations they're generally
enriched for monocytes and one two sites
and our grant low and grand sites and
RBC's and so we get and the scale of
these products is usually about eight to
twelve isms along but they can be more
on so the scale creates problems because
we have so many cells to process one on
the pack there but the great thing is
that if we can effectively process that
we can get lots of purified cells from a
single donor that can be crier preserved
and used across a whole screen or can
can be consumed all at once so it
creates a lot of
researchers if they can effectively
process impacts and for these immune
cell assays essentially and it's even
more viable in the rear cell space where
we really need a lot of starting
populations of cells just to get enough
cell number to do any athletes at all
okay so that's just kind of a basic
introduction clearly Quebec so again the
key thing here is that they're really
Excel products of about 10 billion
little cells that are in those 10
billion cells are essentially similar to
ppsv okay so the virology offers fully
automated Luca packs rolling okay so
we'll talk more about the specific
features and capabilities but really the
key idea here is is that you can
actually go back to the system along
with all the other required reagents and
it's tubing sent and then a single
flower one that's fully automated the
prodigy can cycle the sample so it has
on board certification capabilities to
do take Eurasian tradition and it takes
that sort of PBMC sample and then it
will magnetically sort population using
magnetic beads from no planning
and they can use any of our research
technology beads so lots of different
different types of cell T cells B cells
modified pcs all these different cell
types can be sorted on the prodigy and
then after the photos are sorted because
it has on boards interrogation and
delayed wash though it can formulate the
final product and a suitable volume for
a downstream oscillating and it can
process up to this key number the
holding back and it will kind of look at
this in comparison to other technologies
and a little bit like the automatic and
the timing but it's really really much
much faster to use this instrument
versus other technologies that are in
the market and marina the prodigy can
run these fully automated out days is
that it takes all the sort of male
devices or lab devices that you would
need our functions you would need and it
integrates it into a single platform so
we have magnetic cells orion silvermax
collection systems open and really the
key thing is your interrogation onboard
so the ability to automate instigation
opens up really a lot of different
complex assays and Campos
because we can always wash sample we can
write we can wash them we can do to the
gradient can exchange buffers all these
types of things that are really hard to
do with automation so automating
certification isn't really challenging
thing to do the tipping set that we
install and we'll talk more about this
to music there's quality for the work
with research samples and other electric
and connects aren't real comfortable
with working in bands other things and
these tubing sets but the two things
that also offers biosafety containment
without an external the entire process
is run in bags and it's kept away from
the operator and then we don't need the
tissue go train together in the
microscope just to purify cells but in
the mogees the example will also show
you how the system can do automated cell
culture and expansion itself and as a
microscope for their PC so really when
you look at all these functions put
together the product you can really be
performed to run virtually any cell
washing out purification or expansion
process and give you the cells that you
want these primary cells and exactly the
final formalization desires so we can
really program with either cheese just
about anything and no matter the
complexity given its capabilities so if
we look at the instrument and it's kind
of basic features and all kind of work
from the touch screen on the right and
around in the clockwise fashion through
these so in the touch screen is how you
interact with the strands of the system
um it has a graphical user interface
that it's really straightforward to get
the system up and running program
there's a magnetic separation unit built
in on our hand side there's this two
Szilard barcode reader the two scalar
allows you to seal tubes so when you're
done with your cell selection and you
want to take your target cell off the
instrument you can just crimp the tubing
and break it and the solver contained an
unsterile bag Berko reader lets you
track lot numbers and other things
there's no bag compartment here at the
bottom that could century where your
target cells go and and your non
particles or waste which is the place
where as a different bags are placed and
held don't have this really key features
at centrical it unit this is the century
Asian system so what it allows us to do
to integrating and sell while sharing
but it's also the cultivation inside the
same chamber that we would spend the
cells to do since we creating it they
can also be cultivated in that chamber
and then we have a peristaltic pump
liquid sensors and pinch valves which
control the fluidics of the system and
the flow of buffer around all the
different tubes and the tubing set and
then finally we have a gas mixture in it
because if you want a cell cultivation
gas mix so you can hook up the external
carbon dioxide oxygen sources these
types of things and control the
cultivation environments within the
central Indian air and then finally have
these bag hangers which is holding the
reagent buffers media bags all digital
things go on top but just kind of a
quick overview so many people are
intimidated by your ecology and most the
intimidation comes around the ideas a
hand-painted bag so I certainly in my
scientific career I've never handled in
bags and found it kind of overwhelming
but when you're working with very large
sell products it's actually advantageous
to keep things in bags because now we
can meet a lot of times where we don't
have a million two to running around the
lab trying to find enough such
conditioned space for them or things
like that
we just keep everything a bag for
everything scale and the looper back
itself comes in in a bag and so it can
be just directly connected onto the
tubing set among the buffers and
everything normal
so the other thing is the tuning stuff
looks really complex and this was really
talking not that it it is complex in
terms of its design but it's not hard to
install because it has this mounting ace
so it comes on a blue plastic sheet and
you hang that over the pension and
essentially that aligns the different
tubing line and it's directly the
without go through and then there when
you're in sewing the TV set there's also
via the graphical user interface
on-screen there's an installation guide
so it's walking through step-by-step how
you install your tubing set so anybody
can learn to do this it's not
complicated at all it just takes some
time so you're their budget about 30
minutes in the morning if you want a lot
of prodigy
so sort to get your product connected
your reagents connected into achieving
tonometry
but then the rest of the process is
really automated so you might have
contracted system so hopefully that
makes the TV set and usage banker less
beautiful career um so the really key
feature again is the central unit um
it's really an idea
you
20:50 created with baikal as it would be
done to and then the cells are spun in
3d space and essentially they layer just
a stable tube and you can see here when
I'm drawing this arrow in this window
you can see that layering effects so we
have on the inside of these dense
material is the plasma and buffer and we
have this small white ring that is
leukocytes and on the outside we have it
with recites and granite sites from the
product so if you've done if I called
manually you get the same three layers
that you would with that but we can also
do so washing and concentration steps so
it does not only have to be a
psychologist spend itself to the outer
wall in buffer and renew your inner wall
buffer and the way this all works is
essentially we can pull from either side
of centrifugation central copious and
entirely outside wall you can pull
buffer obsolete give different fractions
redesign others if you want to see
what's happening essentially how this is
doing on a bike off it has a layer
detection kicker and what's happening is
shown here at the bottom pair of see
such I'm drawing a narrative it what's
resolved with Celia this is understand
and then the camera turns on and it
looks for different layers and it can it
knows that the densities and calculates
and so on the outside here on the far
right are the earth rejoice in the grant
site you have this bike all air you have
to spin layer PBMC Bosma and buffer and
the system is calculating whether pulled
from the inside of the outside wall of
the me if you're holding it while it's
still spinning the bonds it needs to
pull so that it can leave behind just
the constancy where I call these are
then go forward and do some place of
washing and I gave you that process we
would have you can see somebody's what
you would make manual if I did if I call
yourself so we're going to talk about
leveraging the prodigy to do racial
isolation and a really crossing example
that we've dealt with several customer
time to help them scale it they're
sorting regulatory t-cells the human
regulatory t-cells existed a frequency
of about one percent in TV MCS
so getting enough of them is always a
challenge and so we work with several
customers now on leveraging the prodigy
system to scale up their sorting in
detail pets they have enough to do their
outdate so before we talk about how
we've done that scale up it's useful to
understand how we sort regulatory T so
changing tax technology so the first
step is we do is officially known as
keep ourselves we have this volatility
cocktail antibody the label of 94 so an
anti by entities that label on a two
section a two-step labeling reaction and
we passed that to a column and the
politico.com
are enriched cd4 T cells which you can
kind of see the results of what does
look like from this kit was where I'm
drawing the marker now you continue to
do that
enriching 14 cells and then in the next
step we take the that pre enriching for
T cells and we now label them with cd25
microbeads so cd25 is expressed on
regulatory t cells it can also the
expected expressed on other activated t
cell populations but it can be used as
an Englishman technology to enrich and
purify ready to serve T so so we label
them the PD tweak of microbeads we do a
positive selection through the column
and the Espada's inoculation and you can
see that the isolated period exceeding
for upon the cd25 phenotype italy would
expect from regulatory t so okay so
moving forward if we look back a few
years before we started doing this work
and we take someone who had an on max
crew and they wanted to get as many many
people as possible what would be their
work from what would their days look
like using traditional sort of next
technology they was probably getting a
look back again of about 10 billion
cells and they would do their standards
by call which would take them 99 I mean
they would start to station bead
labeling so hit by but the deep cocktail
on they take 15 minutes but then
purified is pre enriched the tv-14
self-oscillation if they were leveraging
a lot of X Pro really the maximum number
of cells they could cross with amount of
X Pro and single Don or single day by my
calculations about 1.4 billion cells so
even though they had 10
so not all 10 billion soldier gets
processed on Dateline it's not really
possible and the actual depletion of
that cost on an ex-pro for those 1.4
billion cells will take us about four
hours so it's a really big model in that
can happen
first it's not fast enough this
completion has to be run really slow and
turned gently to get a good thing for
purity and because of that and the
desire to grow and the starting number
so it's still pretty high and outside
that kind of normal max range it takes a
while when we do it so on the bead
labeling again this is the main you'll
be labeling or doing another subtle wash
and now we go back to our autumn expo we
did that peak by positive selection that
takes about 20 minutes and then we do a
cell wash and then finally we're ready
to start our downstream now say hello
it's okay but the problem is we spent
seven hours getting the tea bags which
are probably you know not more than a
few me tea bags from only one point four
billion cells and we've had three hours
of hands-on time and at the end of the
day because I really perfected in coming
in for 10:00 a.m. so we're not giving
ourselves to 5 and iPhone is going
either work asking so I'm going on so
and even at this long day our scale
isn't really what we'd like to get we'd
really like to compress and so what we
worked with these customers I had this
workflow on was really leveraging the
prodigy to change both the scale on the
car so now we are going to work at a
pool to get back scale so we're going to
take that total tending totally fit
adults and process it all in one runs
the whole respects going to get run
again the work that we need to do the
main working need to do is setting up
the prodigy so if you project tubing set
and that we've got connected on to the
system and then we press go and once we
press go something really magical
happens essentially automated cell
processing so all those steps that were
manual steps for us that were time six
o'clock of time for us to process those
cells and that'll even lower scale and
we were running before start to happen
completely automated so everything
happens without of time you can be there
without attending
do anything and it's a really great perk
people reviewing t work and our total
time is an hour and a half or so faster
than an hour scale eight to ten fold
higher than what it would have been
among automatics and our hands-on time
is it tenfold bus as well
so ultimately this is a much better and
much more implementable system for
people doing bringing Tory t solar many
alternatives that were available before
and so this has been really great for
people returning to work with teaming so
we kind of take another example and look
at a common workflow and could even
expand on the amount of automation you
can use and how we could leverage the
trees automation capabilities even
further we can look at generating
automated monocyte drive-in critic so on
prodigies we're going to fully automate
this problem so the pockets start very
similarly to what we discussed for the
very literary keynotes we're going to do
the processing of the eighth research
project we're back and we're going to
have several washing and certification
steps to get it ready so basically you
need PD MCS where we have a simpler
sorting procedure now because we're just
going to do direct selection of modified
by labeling with cd14 micro means and so
we'll just purify monocyte based on
fresh from cd14 once we have those
purified monocytes we can differentiate
them towards the dendritic cell lineage
by culturing in certain media and
cytokine mix that happens an eccentric
halt unit which is in this flow graph
called the cell culture chamber down
here from drawing the air so this is
again kind of a picture of its intricate
unit and the zones are seated into the
central Ament and maintain their across
this a one-week period of them being
differentiated into pcs and then finally
at the end of the process we can do we
can get the cells out of this color wash
their samples and do some final product
formulation and move on with our assay
and so this whole is a one-week process
is completely contained and automated
within on a batch prodigy
so the national not affect period after
this election with hives of cd14
selection per month on cure and we get
about 85% site present that we seed into
the culture and we looked at this and
compared this versus the cell culture
chamber which is the central unit okay
so the left strap here this is the
central unit this one and then in the
bag is kind of a similar scale to attend
chocolate gaming large-scale patient
right into in critic so and then the six
well protocol which is a very standard
research scale protocol and what you can
see that is in terms of both recovery
and my ability the gyration dendritic
cells was identical to back base or six
wrong communication and when using
electrical unit and I'm not going to
share the data just because Tiger
requirements really of course difficult
I mean if it's not secure with their
phenotype consists of exactly nobody
sees and so if you are worried about
that we can service your daily duties
and so you can see that you can automate
these really complex out they would
deposit including cell cultivation of
routine cell types and so the kind of
some of the prodigy section we can only
hold it for backs and do lots of
different improvement so it can be a
simple as volume reduction in media
exchanges which only take ten minutes to
watch themselves and then all of a if I
call no customers were leaving the
prodigy systems just for the generation
of people receive from your commands and
they're not doing cell selection all the
time they're sometimes Julianne
everybody takes a little more than an
hour and then we have planer washes on
some of the loop of research products
relatively little RBC content and low
granitic content and because of that we
don't actually need a full by call
procedure to process windows we can just
be played washing and indirect max based
cell sorting and so if that's the case
we station times mommy did it by
Carlotta Cochrane so they are the
different products that are out there in
the marketplace in terms of early quacks
when the different internships probably
exact argument if I call or the plate
Allah
Brooklyn I'm going to be turning it
taking between say three to six hours
remember something the more complex the
procedure the longer it takes here
actually teacher I don't know this
self-purification both expansionism like
I said in DC that can be between six
hours of calculation time up to two
weeks or even more it's really just
dependent on your needs so again we
can't do anything that you would
potentially me too so if you have
specific applications I have definitely
a job to us and we're happy to discuss
them get plenty of experience in
supporting these applications and
helping customers get things up and
running on the furniture denominated so
moving on kind of another platform down
this next section is doing kind of its
own having one really big sample now
we're thinking about well I had a lot of
samples coming in my lab and I can't
really process
here's my cells fast enough so I have 20
or 40 or 60 samples that I need to cross
with all at one to between the blood
from patients on clinical trials it
could be different tissues from mouse or
animal models and because of the number
of samples and I just can't get my work
done and - we've developed this multi
next x instrument and then we'll take a
specific example in and look at the
isolation not still before we picked a
kind of rare case that incredible so
before we could divine design an
automated instrument really needed a
better manual max order
sorting and so a couple years ago we
developed this multi neck cell 24
instrument it's a male device it allows
us to process between one and twenty
four samples in parallel with other
times of lessening on commute we through
our data it uses these fuse blocks
columns that are 24 columns they're all
teams together they have a sort of 24 L
format and also we developed this a
cumulation technology so what I'm
drawing the arrow is this is the vacuum
station so it's generating the vacuum so
it's your a pre vacuum
and also there is the vacuum chamber
where the block is placed so the block
of columns on the air now fits into this
vacuum chamber and the cells are
basically sucked off the column by that
came to impulse technologies of the
earth and said I'm going to do this
plunger because via 24 Steinberg manatee
plundering other things that would kind
of be gave the speed advantages of doing
this multiplexer we've developed a
different evolution technology and then
finally because of the DeMeo use device
it's really easy to use as fast enough
and military requires so you can use it
on most of my trainings for multi-max X
is 4 cups promoting X's are between 5
and 15 X depending on your application
so you can really get up there new
systems like that we have many customers
start using us for their various
applications that I think the natural
evolution for them was like we like the
multi Mexico I have a multi max it's
more like an automatic so then it's
automated to do social selection and so
kind of listen to that and we talk to
people in the market that need to these
things and so in the last 18 months
we've developed this new system called
the multi micro X which is the automated
version of the multiaxial tree or and it
really sort of it serves all sort of
high-throughput magnetic cell separation
so the example we'll use today is really
parallel processing goes up to 24
samples per run to a 24 individual
samples in our process system can also
book process larger cell products up to
about the happy pathetic scale using all
24 columns for singles sample and
unfortunately just because the timing
requirements
I'm not going
we can run a positive and untouched
isolation strategies and all of our
decree agents you can start with all
different types so starting to do so one
base materials from narrow
funky cook look effects purified PBMCs
under the exampleif later its associated
tissues and in our case associate tuners
we have customers in the immunology
cancer in stem cells that are all using
successfully and there is they stop the
software reagent and sample tracking and
documentation available so
if you have means forwarding batch
records or inflict at our integration
activities blend systems pella possible
using the system so good looks kind of
inside the systems to take the out one
way and kind of look inside what what's
inside the month in that crack so here
we have the one thing excel 24 separated
it looks pretty much identical to the
nanodevices slightly modified but it's
very similar we can have that backing
station that we talked about before and
there's basically a hose that runs
underneath the deck to the to the
aleutian chamber where again we'll use
that vacuum then post to a loop with
sample copy column and then over here on
the left-hand column system we have our
sample racks and these are two racks on
our reagent racks all the examples and
henry agents are kept cold we can use
five no tubes 50 no foods 50 mechanicals
so really a lot of flexibility on what
type of sample container you want to use
for your own based off your samples and
then we have a buffer trucks soviet
controller buffer the pdfs base program
is the X to the X or disposable tips in
the column or name we have these storage
result on the back where we keep more
equal place more tips and we actually
think that in case the robot runs out of
the ones and it's using like there are
none of those particular tips they will
just go get more tips from concave run
sort of stop operating for more tips it
just go to get selves
one of the real challenges with building
a system like this where you build it
into a food in but if you could do this
yourself with other commercial
technology or Hamilton but every time
you want to change the programming or
the multi programming you have to
writing scripts and the software is
pretty hard to use and automation expert
to do that you have none of those
challenges with their system so function
is a dedicated built order you would
open up the script for your application
this is the script will use the tool
selection that we talked about
just a second by slitting tell tumors
and it just tells you which column block
you're using 24 fuse columns your sample
container you want
put your 250 ml conical and your number
of samples you're sampled on your cell
count did you feel - and you can even
put there all things feel if you need a
different cell count for each sample
visually you can click the radio button
over here on the side Johnny's arrow and
you can enter those I'm going straight
into those you can assign sample ideas
so you can assign individual employees
samples if you want to do that and then
you can change the watch timers for
different things if you want to watch
slower or faster than our standard
recommendations you have a lot of
flexibility and then at the end of that
brought those through just hitting the
play button and your run happening so
the system result it just mainly need to
do lot of consults elections for a lot
examples but you can expand adoption and
automate activity further by integrating
additional external robotics so there's
a port on the back of the system bill
allows you to transfer the the isolated
cell populations to another robot so you
can actually put the samples out into
another robot this would probably be
most useful tonight automated cell
culture robot and you need to find
myself to be seated into them and then
the other option would be the
integration of flow cytometer sizes
system each specific picture of our next
quantum still integrated into the multi
next X and you can see that it's
actually looking at the next quad of
autosampler is reaching into I'm drawing
this red arrow now it's reaching into
the deck or the multi architects to
accept samples from the multi matter
expert it will come over the automated
QC or phenotypic analysis of those
purified observations so you can fully
on in a book itself isolation and also
came to balance as your QC 8 April
teasing integrated post atomic
capabilities to say I need collab a pair
um so the example I'll use to kind of
show utility the system
tonight these tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes which are quite interesting
lots of oncology applications and then
these malfunctioning to be modest in
jannat to new model house tuners in life
- they're not human tissues they exactly
I'm not certain of that
okay so the workflow we use force in
genetic tumors attending to how we
actually process these data as we start
with a mouse tumor that we would be
expected in a tumor we associated using
a lot of like gel Mac system along with
enzyme action tuber association mouse
and then at the end of that we get
single cell suspension and we have to
make it through focus missions within
the Excel isolation of individual cell
population in this case the kill
population and we do this with our total
isolation kit mouse until isolation came
out it's based on cd45 selection
infiltrating cells - all white cells in
pronouncing system expressed to be 45 so
step K an enrichment of all the means no
tumor microenvironment
which gives us isolated cells and then
those isolated tools can be analyzed by
Amina Pina temping at our example many
customers are doing if some of the
worker but they're not including this
tool selection step they're just
associating the material and going
directly to kill self-oscillation
analysis so we'll kind of discuss the
value proposition on why customers are
interested in adding the selection set
with tuners and and what does that mean
we're going to I had the usual to add it
seems a little counterintuitive
sometimes to add an additional step when
you could just have a directory of your
till after the association so what kind
of discuss back and you can be talking
about the other thing is if we add with
extra step one of the big concerns those
you will have is how fast is with how
much work can I get done given person
time and so this is really a graph that
we put together in a study we did
accounts for each of 24 mouths to nerves
and process them
through the whole the whole work flows
into the Coleman penny prep and only use
one FTE one technician constant work and
so the first hour of that person's day
was really respecting in this $24 tutors
and getting them the enzyme mix and the
gentle max tubes and so they're able to
get all 24 to retire in our and then we
have this green area which is the
processes automated
to genomics octaves with Peters ever set
up on 24 to and we run these
associations all at once and in 40
minutes via sacra self suspension minute
technician doesn't filter election
spinning and resuspension sample to get
it ready to load onto the multi map X
and then again we have this green arrow
loaded self selection of the till
enrichment athletes fully automated on
the multi X so with a single person in
about three hours of time you can image
like tail so it's really quite fast and
really all you're adding is about an
hour of additional work saw separation
stuff so we're kind of return to this
idea well I could directly read my tumor
my till were directly off my dissociated
material I would I detailed Richard and
so it kind of comes back to two points
one is it reduces your time to data so
it takes less time to flow analysis to
the protein detecting in your sample
versus my language sample and there's
also this idea of increasing as a
sensitivity so your your signal to noise
ratio is better than rich and poor
metals on a quick sample so in other
examples we can calculate a time the
back sample acquisition emitted by a
really simple formula and again kind of
ideal world calculations we can take our
tilt acquisition target or how many
tools do we actually want to acquire and
in all the examples all needs that we
want at least a hundred thousand cd45
causes or events in our data set we
divide that by the tilt frequency so how
a Munden our material in this particular
tumor is one percent of with durable
stone in Damascus which to Brazil or the
ten percent where and then our
acquisition rate how many events per
second are saitama to run that and if
you take that expression divided by
sixty seconds we return
of Akron so we can look at this into
some of a basic grid of timing and where
you can see it it's a really keeping is
here that the lower the top frequencies
so one percent on frequency our runtimes
all much longer than they would be you
can see that this line here is where the
top frequency for this line is all one
percent it's much much slower than when
our tilt frequency is forty percent
right and we have more targets we
acquire our data faster and the only way
to decrease the time of acquisition is
to speed up the actual acquisition rate
to give along this top line here so this
is saying we're either acquiring a
thousand events per second or 10,000
minutes per second and this graph that
I've got here that are kind of annotated
it's just telling you your time an
acquisitions first single gained upon
and so in our air samples if your till
presence is really low and you need on
2010 it can hit you really a long time
even at fast acquisition rates to
acquire a single sample so it might take
you 15 minutes and a 1% kill frequency
to acquire and there are mouse models
that exist with some frequency low so
the b16 Canela model is a crusty example
of a little sort of still not all depend
on Tillamook so analyzing these can be
really quite challenging a lot to deal
with kinda shy away from them we can
kind of do matically change the timing
and the activity by doing enrichment so
we can change this sort of mathematical
relationship by now applying this
condition factor there are such as the
same mathematical equation but now we're
multiplying the denominator but it's
additional factor which we call this
enrichment factor which is what happens
when we do the energy and this is just
empirically determined so the enrichment
factors are just what is the fold
purification of material versus apparent
so if the pair D goes from 1 percent to
80 percent which would be kind of what
we're showing in this first line we'd
have an 80 fold enrichment factor for
that sample and these are extra factors
again are sort of empirically turned in
for our experience to different to model
and we know that because consumers the
average getting about 80% appearance on
with the factors
eighty so now when we look at this the
time acquisition is really clusters
around because we essentially register
them all being roughly the same purely
they're all eighty to ninety percent
pure but till and so the acquisition
time is really now only dependent on the
acquisition rate of the Saitama Terr and
it's not really depending on the model
we use so it's really nice and since
that all of our models are knitting on
time but probably even more key than
that is that this enrichment factor sets
what's our relative improvement at a
sensitivity so what is our signal to
noise ratio so even in the de bunda
models we have a two-fold increase in
our signal-to-noise ratio and then
abundant models maybe all the fileted
40% but 80% of the Kilkenny's Maya
lineage and if you're developing the
TESOL therapeutic and I really
interested in t-cell responses and T
cells are only five or ten percent of
this 40 percent then you still have rare
cells to this enrichment by till can
really help with that sensitivity so
again the idea of decreasing the time of
acquisition makes your day a little bit
shorter but it's really the same
richness factor and improvement getting
better data it really is the driving
factor which we have or adding to enrich
measure so we can look at a couple
different models look at some very basic
parameters so this is just looking at
cd45 expression on these tumors so
they've cd45 in the Y and have a counter
stand against our need and the X
direction so cognitions because it says
he'd agree but we should be double pop
isn't it look Kiki 26 is a a colon tumor
it has about 20% cd45 other songs that
could Association the be 1610 right here
in the middle is that rare so type it
only about 1% so what is the 41 into the
breast model rescue alone that
accumulates more tail inserts about 40%
so what you can see is after we apply
the enrichment so we do this lecture to
see 45 boxes you can see that now these
are all kind of clustering around a
purity and certainly for the v16 well
you could see how many more bits you're
really getting and also for all the
models you can see that you have less
45 odd results complex population a lot
smaller and that's really saying that
you're accumulating more than she care
about because you actually want to see
the type you know this upper population
still you don't really care about the
several negative conversations bottom
until you're here having better
population statistics and also less
aggravation time so I was looking at
some some sort of extra metrics you can
see the initial frequency to the
different lines periods we enrich them
to they're generally better than eighty
percent across all these lines and then
they field here between 60 and 80
percent which is consistent with what I
would expect for most Maxwell selection
even in England in translation so the
signal technology definitely works quite
well and enable the ability to enrich to
a federal population so if we look at
kind of returning to that is it
worthwhile to do basically certainly and
we're cell models we beat the clean
seems really communicated secretary
definitely mixed in so if we had 24
samples that we wanted to run and they
took us down here for the time for the
end which till just this part right here
it's going to take us over six and a
half hours to run 24 samples because
even if we run our sitamma 10 dozen
events per second biggest 16 minutes per
sample
and there's an additional caveat is that
we may never actually get to on with our
sample or we might get so many events
and our data file that this encounter
can actually acquire but stops
acquisitions the kids we can't save the
file that big which can also happen or
dates but we can really dramatically
change that timing for the original if
it's by using these tools technologies
to enrich the till and now our time of
analysis is maybe 50 60 minutes because
we're only spending you know 15 or 20
seconds for sample running the tills
using that sort of mathematical formula
in optimum world voice by very clean
you're committing xx so definitely four
layer so miles this cylinder so it makes
a lot of sense and it can make sense
even can more abundant targets depending
on the cell type you were interested
it's a really nice phone tap on the tool
okay so in the last few minutes here I'm
just going to kind of switch gears and
talk a little bit about our new 384-well
footage and Rebecca on X and then in a
last but I kind of talked about acting
immature zation and making drugs making
four states and then I can take question
all right so back on X is a high
throughput site ometer
it supports high throughput screening so
you can run on two different plates
that's right below watch a for actual
screening activities but it's really
flexible and easy to use and because of
its design it can run a single - Rick on
24th back to the commander is insulated
formal plate it can really support any
app in any scale so you don't only have
to think of the X as a screening device
it can really just be a standard set
ometer that happens to be really apps
the system itself is fully automated so
it'll run fully automated active
including labeling and as a three laser
optical bench with a four hundred five
millimeter 488 633 and either lasers
there's eight quarts and channels plus
board inside scatter so it's 10 total
parameters and so it's and it's got a
very small footprint on the real
advantage of the X versus our
traditional platforms is speed so in
order to isolate and only fifteen
minutes if your internet equal update 60
minutes so even if you're just writing
you're actually 292 co-pays and three or
four it's really nice to get done in an
hour
the work that would take two or three
hours using more traditional cytometry
platforms
additionally again the system is very
flexible and I have a lot of automation
so it has two different shaking
mechanisms depending on whether it's
running larger volumes using fax tubes
it has a different Meg extreme mechanism
and exits writing small ones really cold
plates 384 plates which again really
extend the capability perfectly and on
everyday usage diameter the auto loading
function here is really nice it will
label with antibodies or dyes or
anything that you want into nice your
co-pays and 384-well plate in prison
well for this Auto and capability is
really critical because by cutting to a
384-well plate without robotics
it's really quite challenging the
potential to miss well is high unless
you have some some help from automation
or specific like that
and then this is Amit salt designs and
really need for innovation for external
liquid handling system like the
multi-max X or other robotic platforms
or just play-doh tell so my final kind
of final slide is that you can take the
multi-max X and really miniaturize your
assay and lots of people have been
miniaturizing primary slab base for
flood damage sort of 96-well format
pretty routinely when the idea here is
the 9600 so you probably have 100 or 200
microliters of media or buffer and
you're well and if you're doing some
drug reaction or screening or whatever
it means you're going to use less
antibody reagents drug compound but now
as we go to the 384 well plate we have
probably another tenfold reductions were
at maybe 10 to 20 microliters to
reaction on it and now advise doing that
miniaturization we're consuming lots of
those by myself that we work so hard
previously generate maybe four balute
back otherwise so we're getting more
bang for our buck loss Genesis and data
set and then additionally because the
Mac part X is really fast even though
we're moving into the high standards for
well plate we can make it automated and
run fast and buttocks with it and then
finally the the macro X includes some
really great software tools which again
unfortunately I'm not going that talked
about to help you deal with all the data
generate tell me please to analyze and
quickly heat maps which I digest data
quickly and that capability is even
extended a further by this flow logic
software which we're distributing which
handles very large data set very well
and adds lots of options for data
analysis for leads these big data sets
and so I can kind of put all this
together it's really nice I think if
you're the scale of your update really
is
you're going to have a multiplayer that
day and you want to automate anything
more than a couple external amongst it
wonders because I don't need to think
that that permit assured and have plates
loaded onto the system continuously
search you needed to process here twenty
384-well plate today you can do that
type of work and it mostly automated and
so that's kind of the end of my
discussion of these different
technologies and I hope that was useful
so I appreciate you on a time and
attention and I can take questions
thank you dr. Trotter male for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question we will
follow up with you via email after the
presentation let's get started the first
question is you alluded to the
capabilities of the multi-max decks to
process larger cell members but didn't
really give examples can you expand upon
that and also compare the multi-max
access capabilities with that of the
prodigy it's a really good question in
cooking we are talking to walk to
customers about I mean there's sort of a
natural curiosity about which platforms
not I would dated if your primary goal
is really graduating large sell products
with super packs and that is really what
I'm the ecology is a better fit because
it works with sort of told you to pack
scales it get back to that ten twenty
billion dollar range what we see was the
multi-max X when we use it for a large
cell processing is that we probably have
a lot of cases in terms of the total
fundamental process giving you time and
also there's a little bit less
combination we need to make agnesi cycle
or other things so the kind of take on
format it that we can really process um
ix public have to protects is something
around two to five billion cells or not
at the for-loop exact scale and we may
or may not need to fight call depending
on the cell type as the technologies
where we can directly expect cells are
most mexico out by go but it's not
something that we can assure you whereas
the ability is with prodigy to always do
if i call it um really opens up our
entire portfolio of products so they're
both very useful tools in the space I
think that's really where you know it's
not applications returns from the doctor
often we can kind of help you for your
specific application understanding which
instrument might be a better fit great
thank you
next question is can you provide a
little more detail on the integration of
your flow cytometry into the multi-max x
or other external robotics platforms
yeah um another thing that just didn't
really get cell on time on time
requirements um yeah it's pretty
straightforward so the the quad our
system is designed really to integrate
to external robotics especially on that
way so it's pretty easy for us to
parking on the left hand side of the
instrument the applications that
customers are interested in using it for
pretty wide-ranging we have customers
who really are just wanting to use it to
QC their samples so kind of an identity
test after they've done their self
lecture and an example of this is say
you're serving t-cells from convenience
so populations that you're going to
adopt the transference timaeus because
you're humanizing rice or your therapy
so you can have it count because the
quads are also counting it can count the
cell population and also determine the
purity of the t-cell after the cell
selection so your technician is always
going to be the injection can just
directly go ahead it on to be the
additional step counting zone and
turning the purity and then calculating
everything
and then going to the librarians and the
injection so for the court it's really
straightforward in terms of the
integration quickly with you it's more
based on your needs from an application
perspective of the examples what you
want to do for other external robotics
our study it's really again getting into
really your needs in terms of this
specific application we're on and why
you have another of what we want this
interactive and that's really where sort
of our automation experience and our
automation teams dedicated sort of
automation team and applications in
excess to deal with these more complex
issues gets involved and really helps
customers with these specific challenges
that they face and neck specific assets
or credit cards that need to
specifically comment on this but I think
the key point is to come to us with
those needs thank you we have time for
one more question and that question is
you didn't provide any details on the
gentle map platforms that are used to
generate single cell suspensions from
the mouse tumors can you provide
additional details of how this
technology works yeah so this technology
as well for are they served eight years
maybe um it's a two based technology
where the tissue along with an enzyme
index is placed into a tube and that
tube has a little hard to visualize but
it has a cap that is sealed on top of it
has a rotor and stator so a fixed set of
teeth and a rotor that extends around
those teeth and based on how fast we
spin that rotor and the direction in
which we spin it we can define sort of
the mechanical force profile so how much
mechanical force are we serving on a
piece of tissue at a given point in
sociation process such that we can
optimize that force profile so that it's
really the best possible force for
you're getting tissue so it's sort of
when people done that fiddy been done
so leaving we saw enzymes in there too
so there's time conductor if you
understand directory and mechanical
force using the trailers data system but
your hand you know and a more than a
bust or a filter around the top of the
pod no syringe um you can't really
control how much force you're carrying
competition and the ability to fine-tune
workforce and use automation to better
suit issues is really open up the
opportunity to do more primaries don't
work with complex issues and also that
better products at the end of that and
better single conference mentions which
are really useful not only for the max
technology but really for all downstream
app dates so kind of again coming back
to if you have these mean and extremity
petition Association in any given health
issue I would like to once again thank
dr. Trotter Mayo for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots in
Milton Yi biotech for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 24th
2017 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues to news miss today's live
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye